the world of Hyrule in tears of the
Kingdom can get very hostile very
quickly so we've gathered a few quick
tips to keep you alive and well stocked
along the way if you enjoy content like
this let us know with a like and of
course spoiler warning for some of the
weapons resources and locations in the
game
I recommend that if your lawn materials
one of the first stops can be Satori
Mountain which is a great resource to
use to stock up on lots of healing items
and goodies quickly between the apple
orchard flower garden mushroom Grove and
loads of other useful stuff around the
mountain you're hard pressed to find a
more convenient place to find things
clumped together if you continue to have
problems collecting materials though
amiibos are also another option as the
Zelda amiibos drop paraglider skins
along with lots of helpful items and
even non-zelda amiibos drop decent loot
as well you may or may not have noticed
but sometimes link takes a massive hit
and survives with a sliver of a heart
that's because just like in breath of
the wild in normal mode link has
something called one hit protection this
means that no matter how powerful an
enemy attack is it will never flat out
kill link as long as you have full
health and have to do another attack to
finish him off so you can twist this to
your advantage by constantly being at
full health and Link will technically
never die so basically never partially
heal make sure your hearts are fully
topped off a couple caveats to this
though Gloom damage will negate this
effect so it's best to have some
sunderline recipes on hand I recommend
cooking with a couple fish or Meats to
heal your Gloom hearts and top off your
actual Health as well and also just like
in breath of the wild this doesn't
protect you from Fall damage the
elements or blowing yourself up anything
that's a mistake on your part you gotta
own up to it there are a bunch of basic
recipes most that carried over from
breath of the wild and some that are new
that I recommend using when you have the
materials for it five bananas gives a
triple attack buff to help boost your
damage and five iron shrooms gives a
triple defense buff in a tough fight two
or three Fleetwood Lotus with two or
three rushrooms makes a quick triple
speed buff a defense against the cold is
five sunshrooms and defense against hot
weather can be five chill shrooms Endura
carrots are great when cooked by
themselves because they fully replenish
your main stamina wheel as well as add a
little extra remember that in a pinch
the portable cooking pot can be used to
make any meal on the Fly making cooking
before a certain situation much more
accessible
when fighting the elements most players
turn to recipes or clothing both of
these are obviously viable clothing is
the best long-term option since it
doesn't take any resources using it but
recipes work just as well to keep you
nice and comfortable but remember this
game allows other Legacy tricks that
worked in breath of the wild like in hot
weather you can Splash yourself with
water make some mobile cover from the
Sun for yourself and most practical of
all use the fuse function to attach cold
items to your equipment to cool link
down this includes literally anything
Elemental from legendary dragon parts to
measly key spots these will keep you
cool I'm also going to keep bringing up
bombshield jumps until I drill it into
people's heads this fuse combo is hands
down one of the best combos in the game
this doesn't require much technical
prowess all you need is these bombs
pre-fused to your Shield so you're not
scrambling during combat and practice
for a simple Shield jump and from this
point you can run or go on the offense
and shoot them in bullet time it's
generally great as a big red button to
escape a bad situation it's also not
necessarily about getting good at combat
though it's about using the right tools
well and efficiently such as against
stall enemies where normally you may be
scrambling around hitting them wasting
arrows maybe even getting damaged and
wasting more healing items when instead
one Dazzle fruit takes out the whole
bunch and there's no extra material is
used or struggling with annoying little
frocks in the chasms they keep running
away from you just one blizzard Rod
knocks them all out at once or going up
against a bokoblin boss that's giving
you a hard time one puff shroom gives
you an opening to do a sneak strike that
does eight times the damage without
worry or taking any damage and saving
you tons of durability on your weapon
a staple of the Zelda series fairies
make their return and can be found at
specific locations up in the sky what
you want to do is look for these types
of islands with circular ponds they
carry a couple goodies along with
fairies for you to pick up I recommend
crouching jumping towards them or
walking slowly and jumping to catch them
when they're close to the ground so far
the maximum is four fairies but it could
change at any time another way to help
you survive a lot of incoming damage as
well is Old Reliable The Soldier's armor
set with high base defense that can be
upgraded at the Great Fairy this can be
easily accessed early in the game after
completing just one of the regional
phenomena after doing so return to
Lookout Landing shelter where you can
uncover a hidden entrance to the Royal
secret passage which contains all three
armor pieces once you gain the armor set
you can take a bigger beating than
before hopefully these tips will help
you stay alive in the monster in
invested High rule if you think these
tips helped let us know with a like for
everything tears of the Kingdom stay
here on Gamespot
foreign